alright are you ready for the moment of
truth let's drop these two objects at
exactly the same time and see which one
hits the ground first ready three two
one
Wow did you see that the one connected
to the chain landed just before the
other free wait I'd like to show this in
slow motion so you can see that the
weights are accelerating at just
slightly different rates
oh why did that happen I mean most
people most students of physics would
know that all objects on Earth's surface
should accelerate down at the same rate
9.8 meters per second squared but in
this case what happens is the chain
actually whips the weight around so it
accelerates at a rate greater than the
acceleration of objects when in freefall
that's a pretty remarkable result I want
you to think about the bend in the chain
as the weight descends the chain goes
from falling to becoming stationary so
it's accelerating up the tension
required to accelerate the chain up
actually pulls down on the weight
accelerating it at a rate greater than
the acceleration due to gravity and
that's why it hits ground first now this
actually happens to bungee jumpers if
the weight of the rope is appreciable
they will actually accelerate down at a
rate faster than freefall faster the 9.8
meters per second squared
when I went bungee jumping I was aware
of this what is actually true is that as
you fall your acceleration will be
greater than freefall and that's due to
some effects of the way the rope pulls
on you so I'll do an explanation of that
later when I'm not scared out of my mind
I couldn't figure out what the
acceleration was as it was going down
but you know it felt hi fellows
very great increase in your rate of
speech so oh oh my god knows fast huh
loved it